machine learning is transforming
Industries and driving Innovation by
enabling systems to learn from data and
make Intelligent Decisions this has
resulted in a skyrocketing demand for
machine learning Engineers these
professionals possess the skills to
develop Advanced algorithms build
predictive models and extract valuable
insights from vast amounts of data the
era of big data in Estates professionals
who can derive insights from vast
information and machine learning
Engineers possess the skills to analyze
complex data sets extract valuable
knowledge and build predictive models
for accurate forecast process Automation
and optimization decision making
Industries such as Healthcare Finance
e-commerce and autonomous vehicles
heavily rely on machine learning to
enhance processes and drive growth as
businesses increasingly recognize the
power of data-driven insights the demand
for skilled machine learning Engineers
continues to search that instrumental in
revelaging the potential of machine
learning to optimize operations improve
efficiency and Gain operative edge with
the market value of machine learning
expected to grow exponentially now is
the time to enter into the field of
machine learning and become an ml
engineer who are at the Forefront of
technological advancements and Bank
lucrative career opportunities in this
Dynamic field that opens doors to a
world of endless possibilities and
Promises of fulfilling and impactful
career on that note hello everyone
welcome to Simply learn today we will
explore a profession that has witnessed
a huge surge in demand in recent years
which is going to be the next big thing
in the future can you guess which
profession we are talking about well you
got it right that's machine learning
engineer having said that if you want to
Embark your career as an ml engineer
then our postgraduate programming a and
ml can be the right option for you this
arml postdocet program by simply learn
in collaboration with Purdue University
covers a wide range of topics and
provides hands-on experience in
developing Ai and machine learning
solutions for professionals who want to
upgrade their skills and people to a
career in the field of AR machine
learning this course features master
classes by Purdue faculty and IBM
experts exclusive hackathons to help you
master various skills like statistics
python supervised learning neural
networks NLP and much more by covering
tools and techniques like numpy pandas
python sci-fi along with amazing
industry projects so what is stopping
you from building your future in a and
ML and well now course link is added in
the description box below make sure to
check that out without any further Ado
let's get started meet John who has been
working as a software developer in the
IT industry for over five years now John
has been hearing a lot about machine
learning lately and how it has been
revolutionizing the tech industry he
wonders whether learning machine
learning would be worth it and that's
when his colleague Harry helps him out
hey harry I've been reading a lot about
machine learning engineering lately what
are your thoughts absolutely machine
learning is booming right now really
quite intriguing but how can I become an
ml engineer well with the right skill
set you can my friend possibilities are
endless wow that's impressive looks like
machine learning can be a regarding
carrier with great opportunities and
look creative salaries absolutely John
so let me tell you more about the
working aspects of machine learning
engineer in detail we'll start this
tutorial with a quick introduction to
who ml engineer is and next we'll
understand what exactly does a machine
learning engineer do next we'll dive
into the roles and responsibilities of a
machine learning engineer after that
we'll discuss some of the most important
skills that an ml engineer should
possess and finally we'll talk about the
salary and job prospects of a machine
learning engineer so firstly who is a
machine learning engineer a machine
learning engineer is a skilled
professional who combines expertise in
programming mathematics and machine
learning to develop and deploy
intelligent systems that can learn from
data and make accurate predictions or
decisions the role of a machine learning
engineer involves working with large
data sets pre-processing and cleaning
the data selecting appropriate machine
learning algorithms and training models
using this data they often collaborate
with data scientists and domain experts
like software Engineers to integrate
machine learning Solutions into
production environments for optimizing
and fine tuning models for accuracy and
efficiency as well as evaluating their
performance and finally they perform a
thorough effective data exploration and
visualization techniques in order to
contribute for better understanding of
the data and identifying patterns making
informed decisions throughout the
machine learning pipelines so what are
the roles and responsibilities of a
machine learning engineer firstly
problem understanding and solution
design machine learning Engineers work
closely with stakeholders domain experts
to understand the business problem or
objective that machine learning can
address they analyze requirements
identify suitable data sources and
propose machine learning based Solutions
this involves translating business
problems into technical specifications
defining measurable goals and designing
the overall architecture of the machine
Learning System data preparation and
Analysis machine learning Engineers need
to have a deep understanding of the data
they are working with this involves
cleaning pre-processing and transforming
raw data into a format suitable for
training and evaluating models
exploratory data analysis techniques are
often used to gain insights and
understand the underlying patterns and
relationships within the data model
development and evaluation ml Engineers
are responsible for developing training
and fine-tuning machine learning models
this involves selecting the appropriate
algorithms architectures and techniques
based on the problems at hand you will
need to implement an experiment with
different models such as decision trees
neural networks support Vector machines
and much more and finally monitoring
maintenance and iterative Improvement
after deployment ml Engineers monitor
the performance of deployed models and
address any sort of issues that arise
they design and Implement monitoring
systems to track model performance
detect any kind of anomalies and
identify data drift or concept drift
regular model maintenance is necessary
to retrain and refine models using new
data to maintain accuracy and
adaptability so these were some of the
day-to-day roles and responsibilities of
an ml engineer well let us now talk
about the skill set that a ml engineer
should persist firstly they should have
a strong knowledge on programming tools
now strong programming skills are
essential for machine learning Engineers
programming languages like R which is a
free software environment for
statistical Computing and Graphics can
surely help but mainly they use python
python is widely used in the machine
Learning Community due to its Simplicity
extensive libraries and strong ecosystem
so you need to familiarize yourself with
python fundamentals data manipulation
libraries like numpy and pandas and
machine learning Frameworks such as
tensorflow pytarch and scikit-learn also
familiarize yourself with programming
Concepts data structures and algorithms
and additionally knowledge of other
languages like R and Java can be
beneficial secondly machine learning and
deep learning Concepts ml Engineers
should have a deep understanding of
various machine learning algorithms
including supervised learning
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning familiarize yourself with
Concepts like KNN linear regression
decision trees support Vector machines
neural networks Ensemble methods and
much more not just that furthermore ml
Engineers need a solid foundation in
mathematics and statistics this includes
knowledge of linear algebra calculus
probability Theory and statistical
analysis understanding these Concepts is
crucial for Designing and implementing
machine learning algorithms now in
addition to these technical skills
machine learning Engineers should also
put a strong analytical and soft skills
to excel in their roles they need to
think critically and out of the box to
understand problems break them down into
manageable components and develop
appropriate machine learning solutions
they should be able to analyze data
identify patterns and make informed
decisions based on the results and
finally communication skills now
effective communication is crucial for
machine learning Engineers they need to
extend complex technical Concepts to non
technical stakeholders as well while
collaborating with cross-functional
teams and present their findings and
recommendations strong written and
verbal communication skills will surely
help convey information clearly and
concisely which not only enhance their
professional growth but also contribute
to their overall effectiveness as a
machine learning engineer with all that
having said let us now discuss some of
the salary and job prospects of a
machine learning engineer now the salary
of a machine learning engineer can vary
significantly based on various factors
in United States of America machine
learning Engineers are in high demand
particularly in technology hubs like
Silicon Valley in California and Pickups
like New York according to report by
Glassdoor the average salary of a
professional ml engineer is around 109
000 dollars per year now salaries in the
US tend to be higher due to the cost of
living and fierce competition for talent
and entry-level machine learning
Engineers can expect salaries ranging
from 80 000 to 120 000 per year while
mid-level professionals with a few years
of experience can around 120 000 to 180
000 per year and finally a senior level
or an experienced machine learning
engineer can command salaries exceeding
two hundred thousand dollars per year as
well especially in Top tire companies or
leadership positions on the other hand
in India the salary range for machine
learning Engineers is relatively lower
compared to the US but it's important to
consider the lower cost of living as
well now the average salary of a machine
learning engineer in India is around 8.5
lakhs while entry-level machine learning
engineers in India can expect salaries
ranging from 4 lakhs to 8 lakhs per year
and mid-level professionals can earn on
somewhere between 8 lakhs to 50 lakhs
per year and finally senior level
machine learning Engineers with
extensive experience and expertise can
earn salaries ranging from 15 lakhs to
30 lakhs per year now additionally other
benefits and compensation components
such as bonuses stock options health
care benefits and retirement plan should
also be considered but let's talk about
reality it's crucial to know that these
figures are approximate and can vary
based on various such factors so here
are some of the salary deciding factors
of a machine learning engineering
firstly company and location now the
location of the employee company can
impact on machine learning engineer's
salary large technology companies or
organizations with a strong focus on a
and ml tend to offer competitive
compensation packages to attract top
talent additionally the cost of living
in different Geographic areas can affect
salary ranges but salary is often being
higher in Tech hubs or cities with a
higher cost of living work experience
experience plays a significant role in
determining the salary of a ml engineer
generally Engineers with more years of
experience tend to command higher
salaries this is because experience
indicates a deeper understanding of
machine learning Concepts techniques and
real world applications which makes
experienced Engineers more valuable to
the employers out there skill set and
expertise now specific skills and
expertise possessed by a machine
learning engineer can impact their
salaries as well ml Engineers proficient
and popular programming languages like
python are Java and Frameworks like
tensorflow and pytorch and libraries
such as scikit-learn are often in high
demand and can negotiate higher salaries
additionally specialized knowledge in
areas like deep learning natural
language processing computer vision can
also be valuable and potentially result
in higher compensation and finally the
industry that you're working on and the
current demand prints now the industry
in which a machine learning engineer
Works can influence their salary as well
industries that heavily rely on machine
learning and AI applications such as
Finance Healthcare e-commerce and
autonomous vehicles offer higher salary
packages to machine learning Engineers
due to the high demand for their
expertise also it's important to note
that these relative importance of these
factors may vary depending on the
specific circumstances and job market
conditions salaries can also be
influenced by economic factors market
demand and individual negotiation skills
overall machine learning engineers in
both your us India and the rest of the
world can earn competitive salaries and
it's essential to assess the overall
compensation package growth
opportunities and Company culture when
evaluating job opportunities and with
that we've come to the end of today's
session guys I hope you found this
tutorial informative and helpful if you
have any further queries regarding any
of the concepts covered in today's
tutorial feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and a team of
experts will be more than happy to help
you solve all the queries at the
earliest until next time thank you and
keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and of Skilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here